[Music]
hey everyone markman and rip back at the
playstation competition center for
another video on soul calibur 6.
today's subject everyone's favorite ring
outs oh
yes you know anybody who's played soul
calibur in the past you know both the
joy and the pain
of bringing someone out who has full
health we're also gonna be touching on
the walls in this video so let's get
started
and talk about these stage boundaries
the stages in soil caliber six each have
unique designs in terms of their shape
and their layout
on many of these stages there will be
some edges with no barrier if you hit
someone with a suitable move towards one
of these edges
you will score a ring out and they will
immediately lose the round regardless of
how much help they had
this lets you make an extreme comeback
in the blink of an eye
it's important to know that not every
move has ring out potential even if your
opponent is right up against the
boundary
you'll have to pick and move that
knocked opponent into the air but there
are usually lots of good options if your
opponent's back is to the edge
keep in mind each character some quirky
moves that let you ring out from lots of
odd angles
even if you're the one that seems to be
at risk
so how do you prevent being hit with a
ring out the best idea is to try to
avoid being in the situation in the
first place
if you sense yourself being pushed
towards the edge try to find an
opportunity to reposition yourself
in or out of the foreground because
movement is so prevalent in soul calibur
you can probably find a way to change
the angle of the fight
before you get to the edge if you do
find yourself getting hit near the edge
of the ring try to take advantage of
aerial control in soul calibur if you
get launched in the air
after the first follow-up hit you are
able to steer your character's aerial
momentum in any direction of your choice
if you steer yourself away from the edge
usually by holding a diagonal direction
on the controller
you can sometimes prevent a ring out
from even happening
what about those edges that have walls
or barriers then well it's not too much
fun being up against these either
being stuck against the wall your
backwards movement is very restricted
and makes it much harder to play good
defense like ring outs being proactive
and trying to avoid the situation before
it even happens
is best if you get hit into a wall
instead of a ring out you'll get hit by
a wall splat
your back will hit the wall and you'll
slide down slowly completely vulnerable
to more attack
in fact you can wall splat twice in the
same combo leading to some damaging
sequences
and even more than that some walls are
breakable barricades that will shatter
when you wasp that into them this
transforms the stage revealing a new way
to ring out your opponent
making it especially dangerous both ring
outs and walls lead to huge damage in
soul calibur 6.
you can prevent this by moving around
the arena that way you don't get stuck
near the edge
and if you do get stuck just be really
patient with your defense you know you
can try to slowly inch away after
blocking the attack and to try to get
away from the edge or the wall you can
also surprise your opponent by using one
of your special attack that flips them
over your back instead
that's it for this episode this tutorial
is made in partnership with the
playstation competition center team
you can sign up for open series
competitions on compete.playstation.com
subscribe to the bne esports channel for
more tutorials
and soul calibur 6 content